and finally new rule next time Apple
wants to do something truly innovative
and really think different they should
try not releasing a new phone because
somebody has to teach Americans that we
don't always have to have something new
or better every year or in the case of
our upside down economic system every
quarter the only people who really need
you to get a new phone every year are
the shareholders but just because they
need to sell it so they can jerk off the
stock price doesn't mean you have to
stand in that nerd line and buy it
you're not early adapting in fact quite
the opposite you're taking too long to
catch on
before we go any further I know what the
people on the nerd line you're thinking
Oh bill how can you say the iPhone 7 is
the same as the 6 the old phone had an a
9 processor and a camera with an
aperture of 2.2 and the new one has an 8
10 and a 1.8 sorry not sorry and the old
phone weighed 143 grams the new one 138
I guess you could keep lugging around
143 gram phone in your pocket if you
want your ass to stick out like blac
chyna
[Applause]
like the way I channel the nerd in my
head okay alright so you I get it I get
it the new phone a thing of wonder they
made the camera work better in low light
which let's face it is only going to
encourage Anthony Weiner
but the question I'm asking is do your
friends really need clearer pictures of
your lunch you've already got in your
hand a device that has all your email
all your music the internet GPS takes
pictures get you laid get you a car and
driver when you're drunk
films cops when they shoot you and oh
yeah it's a phone it does everything but
scratch your nuts for you and I'm sure
there's an app for that
it has Pokemon go and grinder an app
which enables guys do Pokemon and go
[Applause]
so why do I keep seeing headlines like
why Apple needs a new hit the bad news
on Apple stock is only beginning is a
new iPhone enough to snap Apple sales
slump sales slump since 2007 that phone
is made over 620 1 billion dollars to
put that into perspective take the
amount of money Donald Trump has given
to charity and add 621 billion
Americans keep asking why doesn't our
economy work for people like me because
it's not designed to because somewhere
along the way we bought into this insane
idea that everything always has to get
bigger especially sales having a really
good year and then just repeating it not
good enough in corporate America the
stock market is the tail that wags the
dog growth growth holy growth is the
only thing that ever matters better than
last quarter beat expectations eat more
hamburgers for apple revolutionising the
world wasn't enough that was last
quarter and it's not just them it's
every company you have a wonder for
example why shaving needs to keep
reinventing itself men used to shave
with a sharp rock and Keanu Reeves still
does then there was the straight razor
then the single blade then the double
blade razor three blades and now the
cuatro let me tell you something if
you've got something on your face that
doesn't come off after three blades
that's not a whisker that's a tumor or
or look at that wells-fargo scandal it's
that very pressure for growth constant
endless growth even when you're filthy
rich that led them into a crime where
they cheated and deceived their
customers now fortunately Elizabeth
Warren's Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau found out and put a stop to it or
as I see it
cowboy zero Indians one
you